talk to me about why you will not wear
earpieces when you go on stage and
perform dave you said you're hearing
yourself [ __ ] up now that you don't
hear voices normally they sound like
they're like robots talking or something
is that correct
i have not been to an ear doctor
actually i did go to an ear doctor
recently just to get them cleaned out
that was a [ __ ] mess but i haven't
had them tested in a long time i mean i
know what they're going to say you have
ear you have hearing damage tonight
tinnitus in your left ear more so than
your writing like my left ear is kind of
worse than my right because of my snare
drum and my stage monitor when i played
the drums
um but you know i've i've tried the ear
monitor thing before a long time ago and
the problem that i have with it
is it removes you from the natural
atmosphere
sound i want to hear the audience like
in front of me and i want to be able to
turn around and hear taylor right there
and then go over here and hear pat and
go over here and hear chris and stuff
like that it just it messes with your
spatial
i can't even understanding of where you
are on stage and so but you know that
being said i've had the same monitor guy
the guy that mixes my monitors for 31
years i mean the guy is like he's in my
head and so even though i'm not using
in-ear monitors
my the sound on stage for me is [ __ ]
perfect because it's been the same guy
ian beveridge for 31 years since nirvana
so i'm not up there just getting my ass
kicked by some loud stuff it sounds
great and i just don't like the in-ear
things
plus i have little [ __ ] ear holes and
those things when i put them in they
just pop out and i don't want to look
like a i don't want to look like a
praying mantis with like these things
all over my head you know i'm gonna go
out there and go nuts well as someone
who has looked like a praying mantis his
whole life it's not a bad look i've
always looked like that but i but here's
the thing you know you're [ __ ]
yourself up it's like i gotta do it my
way yeah i mean i figured that
we've been playing shows like this for
so long there's not much i want to
change and to be honest when we go in to
make a record and we're mixing an album
dude i can hear the slightest little
things like my ears are still tuned in
to certain frequencies and if i hear
something that's slightly out of tune or
a symbol that's you know not bright
enough or something like that like i
i
in the mix i can [ __ ] hear the
minutia of everything that we had done
to that song like i really can that
being said if you were sitting like next
to me right here at dinner i wouldn't
understand a [ __ ] word you were
saying to me the whole [ __ ] time
there's no way in a crowded restaurant
that's the worst now
that's the worst thing about this
pandemic [ __ ] is like people wearing
masks i've been reading lips for like 20
years so when someone comes up to me
they're like
i'm like i'm a rock musician i'm [ __ ]
deaf i can't hear what you're saying